très bien merci bruno m'a écouté
l'évolution technologique fait que nous
avons aujourd'hui à notre disposition
vraiment des mots des moyens qui sont
incomparables ce que pouvions avoir il
ya une vingtaine ou une trentaine
d'années même si à ce moment là on
cherchait déjà à les mettre de la
meilleure façon possible à disposition
des policiers alors ses moyens vers quel
but doivent-ils tendre il a d'abord
donné du temps et de la disponibilité
aux policiers sur le terrain tout
simplement qu'il retourne le moins
possible à leur base pour régler ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les problèmes
administratifs puisque maintenant on
passe plus de temps à écrire
même si c'est sur un ordinateur un mais
on poste que sur la voie publique donc
là il ya un enjeu absolument fondamental
et ça nécessitera néanmoins des petites
évolutions soient réglementaires soient
législatives puisqu'il faudra bien que
tout ça puisse se mettre en musique de
façon harmonieuse et incontestable
deuxième deuxième chose il faut que nos
policiers et nos gendarmes soient
sécurisés dans leur mission alors
sécurisé dans leur mission ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire véritablement
qu'aujourd'hui il ne soit plus en
permanence obligé de prouver qu'ils ne
font pas mal et que ça ne soit pas les
délinquants qui eux puissent se
prévaloir du reste donc là il ya 2 il ya
deux choses fondamentales
il ya d'abord les caméras individuel
c'est fondamental des mers tout à leur
ont témoigné nous mêmes nous avons fait
l'expérience depuis pas mal de temps
mais sans tout soit étendue de façon de
façon globale il ya un impact
extrêmement forts sur le délinquant
aujourd'hui n'importe quelle chaîne de
télévision vous sort les images que
untel ou untel a pris d'une scène
d'intervention de police évidemment on
ne voit là
que la focale défavorable aux policiers
l'avantagé policiers avec sa caméra
individuel c'est que au moins l'ensemble
de la chaîne
tous les échanges sont répertoriés mais
il faut aller il faut aller il faut
aller un peu plus loin en ce sens que
non seulement il convient que ces images
soient enregistrés au niveau de la
caméra mais qu'elle puisse être reportée
également en temps réel soit vers le
véhicule de patrouille ou le chef de
patrouille peut visualiser sur écran
l'évolution des choses et par conséquent
d'idées les interventions suivantes et
éviter que nos policiers et nos
gendarmes ne se trouvent dans des
situations sur laquelle il n'aurait pas
un éclairage complet et par conséquent
au niveau de la sécurisation et de
l'intérêt des interventions suivantes
c'est extrêmement important
et puis bien sûr report de ces images
vers les salles de commandement
c'est une évidence les moyens
technologiques nous permettent de le
faire maintenant de façon de façon très
fine sécurisation des policiers mais
aussi dit d'âge des policiers faut
absolument que soient les données de
délinquance soit les données des
incidents divers puissent être portées
quasiment au quotidien est parfois selon
certains certains incidents qui se
passent sur tel ou tel endroit de la
circonscription de l'agglomération que
cela puisse être porté immédiatement à
la connaissance de la patrouille qui est
la patrouille l'a la plus avancée
enfin et je terminerai par l'aps qu'il
faut que je puisse un être le plus court
possible pour la table ronde suivante
dans le domaine de la technologie
il y a aussi des nouveaux moyens pour
faciliter les enquêtes et notamment la
preuve vis-à-vis du délinquant c'est
tout ce qui est police scientifique
et là nous allons il ya eu une sous les
dans le domaine de l'adn et puis des
grands fichiers
ion qui ont été induits et on sait qui
les a créés et quand nous avons eu une
explosion statistiques mais vraiment une
explosion statistiques en à peu près 7
ans 8 ans et ça continue ça continue a
abondé avec l'élargissement des
possibilités de prélèvements en fonction
des infractions qui est une phase
absolument essentiel du dispositif et
nous allons avoir dans les temps à venir
encore d'autres avancées technologiques
qui permettront aux enquêteurs d'avoir à
leur disposition des moyens nous je
parle tout simplement par exemple de ce
qu'on appelle déjà le portrait robot
génétique
ça ne parle pas encore mais ça va
bientôt ça va bientôt être possible être
possible et ça permettra aux enquêteurs
tout en ne connaissant pas le vrai
profil adn du délinquant de déjà avoir
un certain nombre de types âge qui
permettront d'orienter son enquête de
façon plus pertinente et puis il ya
quelque chose qui est très terre à terre
et ça rejoint ce que je disais tout à
l'heure en termes de disponibilité de
patrouilles sur le terrain et par
conséquent de multiplication des
patrouilles puisque les moyens sont pas
forcément extensive mais un exemple
simple dans le domaine de la sécurité
routière
tout le monde connaît le système
d'appréhension de l'alcoolémie suffit de
souffler cetera bon très bien ça va très
vite
la décision est prise immédiatement un
de la classification au niveau du délit
ou pas etc
les préventions des stupéfiants c'est
extrêmement lourd il ya bien un
dépistage actuel en premier rideau au
niveau salivaires et encore pour
uniquement un type de stupéfiant
mais c'est après que les ennuis
commencent pour le policiers ou de
gendarmes et une fois qu'il a constaté
qu'effectivement ça peut être positif
il ya tout un système extrêmement lourd
de conduite à l'hôpital et qui ne
donnera pas de résultats immédiats
donc imaginez bien une patrouille qui
fait de la sec
ricker s'ils sont 4 pouces ils sont cinq
quand ils auront pris deux ou trois
personnes susceptibles d'avoir pris des
stupéfiants et bien ma foi ils
disparaîtront il disparaître au du
théâtre d'opérations et là ça va venir
très vite c'est la matrice la matrice
salivaires et des tests salivaires qui
cette fois l'avoueront permettent dans
les mêmes conditions d'avoir de bons
résultats avec des résultats fiables
très rapidement et sur un spectre de
drogue seigneurs plus étendue
qu'actuellement
voilà la merci restitution de temps sur
le terrain et efficacité merci monsieur
le directeur